for his managing director of bulk
powders
you announced last week that you're
increasing uk ti's resources to double
the support for british exporters to
china but for brands like mine that are
looking to expand and grow closer to
home what are you going to do for um
smes that are looking to grow into key
closer markets such as europe and what's
going to ask you what what's your
business what what
sports nutrition brand so we sell direct
to consumers across the uk and europe
and you want to sell into european
markets yeah we currently already do but
we're looking to expand more and more
and there seems to be very little
support for brands who are trying to
grow closer to home right
i mean first of all we shouldn't forget
that europe is a huge market for us and
all the problems you continue to read
about in greece and france and so on
they have affected the british economy
because they directly affect a business
like yours there aren't so many european
consumers who can afford uh the products
that we're making
so that's why we have said look let's
look further afield let's look at these
new growing places like china like india
and the like to make sure that you've
got more options but we also need to
help you when you sell your goods into
europe now
we've we've put a lot more resource into
this thing called uk trading investment
uh i think most people would say it's
doing a lot better job than it was five
years ago but again there's more to be
done i think particularly more to be
done small businesses but i would say
you know if i was trying to identify
some of the big problems for the british
economy going forward it's still that we
don't export enough that we do not
export for example the same as the
german economy and it's often it's not
the biggest companies in britain that
struggle to do that it's often the small
and medium-sized companies that are
having trouble and that's where there is
a big role for government in saying look
this is how you do it have you thought
of this market we can help you in this
particular way and expanding the support
we've done
for we've given to uh ukti something
i've managed to do in every single
budget um adam's wider issue is the
trade deficit deficit's now 35 billion
wider since 2010 well yeah i mean look
the latest trade deficit numbers which
came out uh just two weeks ago actually
showed the smallest trade deficit for 15
years but again this is a question of
you know lots done but still
more to do and
we have got to as a country
earn our way in the world all the things
we want in our country the great nhs the
great education system jobs for young
people these come when we have a
successful economy that is trading
around the world making things here in
britain selling them abroad as you are
doing and we need to back people like
you with competitive taxes economic
stability making sure you can employ
great skilled uh people coming out of
our colleges and universities and
schools
and helping you get into those export
markets and creating a culture in
british business where we we go beyond
our shores to sell we are we're a great
trading nation that's part of our
history and heritage i want to make sure
it's part of our future